one and only mr. Matt Braunger there you  go let's do it oh thanks man do you hear  Jim's copy guys crying it's so amazing  that's amazing  old Cosby no one got old well it's in  salute it's kind of close to front yeah  cause he's just Lord you know things out  oh that's a joke that hasn't died and I  mean that sincerely  you're as funny in 1982 ago putting top  guys still to me the immortal classic  Rudy  yes to notes Vogel lessons or Theo  availabe oh yeah do you harsh your voice  at the end like a bullet ricochet and  I'll take a Dipity dip dip down any day  mean it's really good moves zipped up by  different energy throwing code back from  down by them there I'm there about that  Kodak there when I fell man loves an  endorsement